[Music]
i'm really excited about this episode
because i get to talk to gene olwang
jean
is remarkable
she started her career as an executive
in telecom and mobile phones and she
broke every glass ceiling
but after 20 years doing that she
realized she wanted to do something
bigger with her life
and so she started working in
philanthropy
she's the president and founding ceo
virgin unite which basically houses all
the philanthropies of the virgin company
she's also a b team leader and sits on
the advisory council of elders
but what's most important about jean
is as she was meeting all these
remarkable people doing remarkable
things in the world she discovered a
pattern that in every single case there
was a partnership
that was at the basis of their ability
to work at remarkable scale but also
find great fulfillment in their lives
and this is why i wanted to publish her
book
she understands that if any of us wants
to do something worth doing
and find great fulfillment while we're
doing it
we have to work together
this
is a bit of optimism
after years of working in philanthropy
and doing good and running virgin unite
which is sort of the umbrella for all
the the virgin charities
you came to discover that these
remarkable people have a secret power
all these people that we admire write
books about read articles about we're
all fascinated with that they all do
something
that
gives them their secret power
which is
partnerships
and you know i was just amazed by
watching these great people and seeing
how they became who they were in the
world
and i realized that it was because of
the people they surrounded themselves
with and the people that they built
really deep connections with i think
this is such an important conversation
especially in this moment in time
because we have made
heroes out of
ceos and these kinds of people as if
they're lone wolves i think as a nation
especially in the united states we've
over indexed on rugged individualism
and as we see younger generations coming
up
they struggle to form their words not
mine deep meaningful relationships
and here what you have said is the
ability to form partnerships literally
is the thing
that distinguishes the great from the
good yeah it's the thing that allows us
to have meaningful purposeful lives as
well as the thing that allows us to make
a bigger impact in the world and you're
right simon i mean i think from the time
we're a super young age we are pushed
towards being hyper individualistic so
we've created this world where
loneliness has become one of the largest
problems of our time bigger than obesity
bigger than smoking because we've pushed
people into thinking that they have to
be the one they have to be the superhero
they have to save the day
and we almost have to step back and
figure out how we unlearn that hyper
individualism and how we relearn how to
become hyper-connected oh such i love
that term hyper connected
what did you learn about yourself in
writing this did you
did you change in any way so for me it
completely transformed the way i look at
the world completely transform my lens
from looking at a relationship on a more
transactional basis for example
to
looking at relationships and every
relationship and every partnership i
have
as something that could change me could
change them for the better and most
importantly how we could come together
as a partner to make a bigger difference
in the world can you share a specific
example as we went through this we
weren't just interviewing partnerships
we were also interviewing these amazing
collectives that had done some of the
greatest things in the world some of the
greatest human achievements like the
community who close the ozone hole and
this process shifted the whole way i
look at how we need to tackle
the issues that we're facing in the
world right now and how the first thing
you need to do is build these deep
connections at the center that become
the connective tissue and the
scaffolding for us to really build these
collaborations if you go into a room now
and you ask um who knows who discovered
and closed the ozone hole you will have
almost no one raised their hand and
that's because it wasn't a single
superhero it was a collection of friends
at the very center and it started in
1974 with these two incredible friends
sherry roland and mario molina these two
scientists in a small lab in california
who discovered that um cfcs were
destroying the ozone layer
and sherry and mario felt so passionate
that they had to get this message out to
the world that they quickly published an
article in nature and they thought the
whole world would react
an opposite happened 8 billion cfc
industry started to attack them slowly
all of sherry's speaking engagements
were pulled out from under his feet and
this didn't last for just a day
or a week or a month this lasted for a
decade
and i had the good fortune to meet with
mario before he passed and i asked him i
said how on earth did you weather these
attacks for so long and he said one word
he simply said friendship and it was
their friendship and
really their complimentary skills that
allow us to go out and enjoy the
sunshine today can you share a story of
one of the people that you've met along
your journey
who
may have gone down that rugged
individual path and then discovered that
partnership was the thing that they
found salvation in the partnership we
interviewed over 60 partnerships of all
types friends romantic business partners
family members
and they all had two things in common
one was the longevity of their
partnership and the second was they used
their partnerships to ever greater
change in the world i mean i personally
also went down that path which is why i
wrote the book because i
was focused on for 20 years building
mobile phone companies and focused on
how do i break as many glass ceilings as
i possibly can and then when i started
working with a group called the elders
that was set up by nelson mandela and
archbishop tutu and others again i
started to see they were who they were
because of the relationships they
surround themselves with and for me that
was a massive awakening call about that
was the real meaning of life and so some
of the people that i interviewed like
you had um peter chernin and ray
chambers for example both unbelievably
successful business people unbelievable
and then both of them in different ways
came to this focus on purpose in their
life and then they found each other
and they started this organization
called malaria no more and the reason it
was so successful was because of their
partnership and their deep friendship
and their connection and that when i
focused on interviewing them was the
thing that they said was most meaningful
in their life was building malaria no
more together and most joyful in their
life as well so what was it about
malaria no more that they could only do
together that these two extremely
successful people who understood
logistics and teams and all of this
stuff were probably incapable of doing
if they tried to do it alone or at least
to the degree they did it they'll be the
first ones to acknowledge that they
never could have done it on their own
and what they talk about is how they
both bring different skill sets to the
picture and you know
ray is
so focused on delivery making something
happen peter brought more of an
operational side ray brought that
ability to go out and connect and build
these incredible networks these
incredible consortiums he had worked
with the un as well and they came
together and then they also talk a lot
about how their deep connection at the
center of malaria no more was a start of
building an even bigger collaboration
that was able to change the world and
they couldn't have done it without each
other and i think one of the things that
was so beautiful about their interview
was they also just talked about how it
was the most joyful thing in their life
and that they could almost lean on one
another when the other one was down the
other one brought the other one up and
there was this partnership of just
making sure that they never ever gave up
and they never will give up until they
die around ending malaria in the world
and you know i think simon if i hadn't
gone through this process of
interviewing these 60 partnerships and
really understanding what makes deep
connection work i don't think i would
have found my life partner my husband
chris
um this book and this process of this
interviewing and understanding the
richness of deep connection
opened my heart and allowed me to have a
much richer relationship with him so in
full transparency this book is one of
the books from optimism press which is
my imprint with penguin which i'm so
honored and proud to publish your book
and one of the things that was so
appealing and drew me to it so much was
that you wanted to call it partnering
not partnership
partnership is a static thing and you
maybe have one of those but it's this
act of partnering it's these actions you
take to partner and that you can have
multiple partners and it's an ongoing
skill right it's not something you you
learn and then you're done
can you share one of the actions that is
required for partnering that is perhaps
the simplest for most people to grasp
and maybe even implement out of the gate
yeah and and you're you're spot on that
this is something that's constantly
evolving and you know i think we've been
so pushed towards hyper individualism
that we've forgotten how to connect and
so
these six degrees of connection are
grounding in the how how we connect and
probably your answer to the one about
what's the simplest one would probably
be it's not the easiest one to do but i
think it's one of the most important
ones we need to grasp is celebrate
friction
and you know when i interviewed andre
and bertrand
two amazing individuals who did the
first solar flight around the world
um they talked about this beauty of they
love when they disagree because when
they disagree they called it the
sparkles it means they're gonna learn
something new
and so the celebrate friction is about
how do you turn those moments of
friction into something where you're
going to learn something new you're
going to become better and they love to
say it's not about competing with one
another it's about competing with
yourself to become the best version of
yourself
and so
many of these stories these rich stories
from the 60 interviews that i did
had incredible ways of how they
celebrated friction
for example one was around
come to every conversation thinking
about what if the other person is right
so don't sit in your
own space thinking you're right but
think about what if the other person is
right and come to that point of friction
from that mindset
another wonderful bit of wisdom that
came out was
always go in thinking there's a third
way never think you're locked into two
positions
but thinking about how
through discussion and through open
mindedness and through deep deep
listening how you can find that third
way or like ben and jerry had a
wonderful one where they talked about
that their friendship was their highest
priority and they were never going to
let anything break their friendship that
was the fundamental and so they had
something amazing called veto power
where if one of them for any reason had
such a strong feeling that they could
never agree with something the other
person was saying
they would have a veto card that they
could hold up and they said they have
done that use that very very rarely but
it's allowed them again not to get stuck
in this position of conflict you know in
that whole concept of celebrate friction
i think there's something about like 12
principles we put into the book around
how you can celebrate friction
to turn it into the sparkles and again
compete with yourself to become a better
human being was there a partnership that
you explored that you struggled with
like when
when you saw their partnership like you
didn't understand it you didn't quite
get it you know intellectually
understood it but it was like i don't
get this one in the early days we were
talking about this book you really
encouraged me to go out and find people
from deeply opposing sides deeply posing
and you know there was a few before i
went in that i was thinking okay this is
going to be interesting i want i wonder
if i will be biased toward one direction
the other and one one conversation that
i just
adored but i think i went in with an
unclear expectation on whether i would
adore it was cornell west and robert
george and they're both extraordinary
academics and scholars one is a social
democrat one is a republican
and they both have deeply opposing views
on many topics but they were able to
come together and just have this
extraordinary friendship they talked a
lot about
that sometimes if someone sees them in
conversation sitting in a room
they will think that they're just
sitting there quietly but what they're
really doing is trying to absorb what
the other person just said to really
listen because they have so much respect
for the other person that even though
they may have a deeply opposing view
they want to hold the space to really
understand why
that person has expressed that view and
you know when their interview finished
i'll never forget they they looked at me
and they both said go out and find a
friend that unsettles you
and these partnerships and relationships
aren't just about finding people that
look like us act like us sometimes the
ones that are the richest and teach us
the most are the ones that are most
radically different
and also that unsettle us and challenge
our views and you know there was another
partnership that was just amazing and
again
this one i didn't understand because i
just simply couldn't believe it was true
um and this was azim kamisa and plus
felix very very very sadly this was
probably now about 30 years ago
plez's grandson
had actually shot and killed azim's only
son in a gang prank and
rather than have bitterness
and
never speak to pleas
azim brought ples and plays his family
into his home pleasant azim
then build this extraordinary friendship
and then started a foundation together
to stop kids from killing kids
and when please's grandson who had shot
to zim's only son came out of prison i
think it was just 10 years ago azim
hired him
so that he could also go to schools to
talk about how we need to make sure that
we
build bridges across difference that
we're not driven by fear we're not
driven by hatred and bitterness and we
hold that space for love and for me you
know they talk a lot about one of the
things that kills respect and trust is
judgment
and how you need to open the space up
for not judging and coming back together
and just an unbelievable story of
forgiveness and friendship you know one
of the six degrees is this ecosystem of
virtues and in there is this concept of
unshakable respect and uzo um who runs
the africa center uzo welle he said
something really beautiful around
if you don't listen to someone it's
telling them they don't exist
oh that's good it's beautiful it's just
such a beautiful comment incredible
wisdom within that statement
um and he was talking about that deep
listening and that's where that's where
the respect comes from that's where the
trust comes from i used to say
up until this day
there's a difference between
listening and waiting for your turn to
speak
and i think that's still very sort of
egocentric right it's about me doing the
listening or me waiting for my turn to
speak but because we're talking about
partnerships and we're talking about
something that's interrelational i think
this is even more powerful i'm going to
use this from now on which is
by not listening you're telling the
other person they don't matter when you
don't listen you're telling the other
person that they don't exist
hearing that forces not for you to go
quiet
but for you to do the active action of
listening
yeah it's a it's one of the deepest ways
you can show your respect to someone
yeah watching
ben and jerry over the last whatever 17
years now
i've never seen one
smirk on their face or rolling of the
eye or any type of body language that
ever undermines their respect and their
trust for each other
and so it's those small things that we
do every single day
that really bring to life this ecosystem
of virtues of you know trust respect
belief
generosity gratitude you know it's it's
those small things that we do
and i remember someone in virgin once
saying to me that um
in every single interaction we can
either win or lose the culture we can
either show someone that we love them
and build a culture that really is human
or we can do the opposite and destroy
the culture in a moment
so i mean basically what we're doing
here is we're saying parents you have to
do a better job schools you have to do a
better job
companies you have to do a better job of
setting incentives
and creating a culture in which people
will share
and collaborate and partner
rather than be preoccupied with their
own success their own bonuses
their own careers to your point there
was an amazing interview i did with
sangudeli who built an investment firm
in africa he started it with his three
brothers and the entire company has
shared prosperity so whether it's the
person that
cleans the windows whether it's the
person that serves food whether it's the
secretary whether it's the ceo they all
share in the prosperity of the company
and he said that has made such a big
difference because they feel ownership
and that came from his mom because there
was something beautiful that his mother
did with the three brothers where
she didn't reward them as individuals
she rewarded them
as three brothers so when one was
successful all three were rewarded but
also when one made a mistake
all three
were told that they needed to do better
and it was that sharing as brothers that
a built incredible relationship between
the three but made them want to
cooperate and made them want to work
together you talk about ben and jerry
how they never gave any language there
was no
any body language that gave away no
disrespect for the other that that that
in quite the opposite showed respect for
the other
have you ever heard the um
i don't know who came up with it but
there was a famous relationship
um
uh
therapist i guess
who said that he can tell in the first
five minutes if the relationship is
going to survive or not
of meeting he says he meets a couple and
he can tell in five minutes if no matter
how much therapy he gives them whether
this is going to survive or not and if
one starts talking and the other one
rolls their eyes he says it's over it's
done there's nothing he can do because
all respect has broken down yeah and
that's why these partnerships had these
virtues basically there were six virtues
that came up again and again and again
and as soon as you roll your eye or you
turn your back on someone
you again you're telling them as we
spoke about before that you don't exist
or that i don't care about you
and there becomes this imbalance in the
relationship that is really hard to
repair over time if that continues and
all 60 of these partnerships you know i
was just thinking when you're talking i
can't remember a moment where i saw one
of them do anything that would undermine
the other partner and it was super
interesting simon because when i started
this process 15 years ago i remember
everyone saying to me you have to find
the fights you have to find when people
are just you know going at each other
and how they get out of that
and i tried really hard in the first set
of interviews to find that conflict
and what was really beautiful and some
of these partnerships i know really well
so i know there was conflict at times
but was really beautiful was something
that that i now call positive amnesia
because these partnerships had that
friction
but they were able to forget about it
and they didn't hold it so you don't see
a role of an eye or because they don't
hold that disrespect they they work
through it they figured out how to
celebrate that friction and then they
moved on
and so you didn't have that as a theme
and met in any of the interviews i did
are there any questions that you have
yeah i think simon you have this ability
to
succinctly and you help me so much
succinctly get this idea in the
beginning to a place where it was
something that could grow and build what
attracted you
to this book i like to say that there's
an entire section in the bookshop called
self-help but there's no section in the
bookshop called help others
and what we need in this world is a
section called help others we've all
learned the skills of putting ourselves
first
i think we as a society are lacking the
skills on how to put others first and
the concept of service and giving and
suffering and sacrificing for greater
good so that others can join in that
success or planting a seed that someone
else may enjoy the shade of that tree
i think that we're a little bit out of
balance
and so
that you had exposure to so many
remarkable people and remarkable
partnerships and more important that you
were able to discern patterns
in all of these partnerships and they're
so different
from creative to business to changing
the world stuff to sometimes opposite
personalities they're so different that
you were able to discern that these
patterns meant that we could learn
something about how to partner better
that we could learn how to help others
better and that more than anything else
profoundly drew me to want to help you
tell your story thank you so much simon
for for believing in this book i love it
i have it here for anyone who wants to
learn more about how you can partner uh
you can pick up partnering
forge the deep connections that make
great things happen by gino wang
at find bookstores everywhere and some
not so fine ones
gene you're so magical so inspiring
thank you so much for taking the time to
tell us about it i love it thank you
thank you so much simon thanks for all
you do in this world
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and would
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other